but let me try and explain all of the
index and log walls in that sense all
right for instance what does this mean
as an identity right what does it mean
in terms of birth and of time per second
think about what all the pieces are here
okay the idea is that if I'm growing at
a rate a okay and if you let it grow for
one time period okay how much bigger
will it be at the end of that time
period it's all it'll be eight times
bigger okay now what does that mean over
here if I rewrite this
okay what's the UM what's the
corresponding log law for that index law
cuz all the world wars are just
rewritten in this bit so if I've got
something right it's growing at rate a
and you ask me the question well how
long will it take for me for it to be
eight times bigger right then my answer
is it'll take one time period okay now
let's think about another one how about
this this identity okay what does that
mean in these terms I've got something
and it's growing a train egg what does
the zero in the code it means I don't
given any time to grow okay so zero time
is elapsed so this is my starting point
okay and the starting point is it's at
size one I seen a hundred percent okay
it hasn't gotten any bigger hasn't
gotten any smaller it's just there it is
okay so therefore the law all that goes
with business is log base a base because
the base of one is equal to zero so
think about again re worth it
I've got something and it's growing at
rate a how long will it take me this
isn't a time question right it's all
things time how long will take me to be
a hundred percent on the size of what I
am right now
answer it doesn't take me any time I'm
already there does that make sense okay
let me keep going this is where it
starts to get fun okay
what about a fee about this okay
hey the power of minus one what does
that mean that's one on a right how do
you rewrite this what log board goes
with this maybe I should ask us this
instead what does this mean in terms of
birth and time and rates and all that
kind of feel this means I've got
something it's growing at Rite Aid
what does minus one correspond to I'm
going backwards in time I'm going
backwards in time okay so what effect
does that have on my final birth okay
well for instance suppose my growth rate
was two
okay well if I'm doubly right and I go
backwards in time one unit how big was I
one unit ago namely I was half the size
I was before right and then you come
forward and you're like oh I'm back to
normal size okay so therefore I think
about this as logs okay what if I say
this this gets a bit trickier I say this
this will be a little bit different okay
just so I can try and illustrate it
okay I'm going at rate a and I want to
get 2x times bigger than I am okay but
there's a minus sign
what is that signifies well you guys
know how coefficients work at the front
right this is going to be equal to
coefficient becomes the index right so
this is going to be log base a of 1 on X
do you agree that make sense now what
does that mean what does this correspond
to remember logs all of this is about
time okay so when you see a minus in
front of a log that means you're going
backwards in time that's when you were 1
over X in science like say half the size
that you are now as you're growing okay
okay let's figure out this let's think
about how logs go together because this
is where it gets confusing okay I'll
give you a concrete example first
because that might be a bit easier if I
say once you grow to six times my size
I'm growing at rate a and I one get it
six times bigger okay I can think of
that as the time it takes to double in
size okay so now entices B and then the
time after that to get three times
bigger right so if I go twice as big
take that plug and then grow three times
as big and take that time and add up
those times that's this right do you see
each of these refers to a time so when
you add up these times because the
growth multiplies that's why you're
gonna get log of say M okay this is the
product rule is equal to and boss and
these two times are separate and then
building on each other does that make
sense okay let me give you another
example let's let's take this line okay
and just do some simple arithmetic on it
let's do this
subtract this right from both sides
now remember I said this is all about on
there's all that times right so what
does that line mean remember what we set
up here right if you see a minus in
front of a long term right that means
you're going backwards in time okay so
let's look at the left-hand side this
amount of time is the time it takes you
to get six times bigger okay so that
amount of time elapses okay but then
there's a minus sign which means you go
forward and then back in time the amount
it takes to double right that make sense
so if I go forwards this amount and then
backwards this amount so I've grown six
times in size and then I've have myself
right no way everything here is like
this you see what's doing I've turned a
positive now okay the time it takes me
to grow six times bigger and then in
time it takes me to grow half my size
which happens to be negative right
that's going to be only three times
bigger right which is where we get the
division ball okay so you can say log -
does this make sense so I think that the
break should be you need to get is that
when you see long equations think time
think duration how long does this thing
take to get to the size that it is